I'm here in Bangkok with my good friend
here the taxi driver what's your
name Tong very good very beautiful very
nice
country I saw a white man uh
European looks like a European Guy and
um he was um he was being very abusive
and abrasive to
the foot
massages uh so I had to intervene you
see and he was uh not expecting it uh
we're here in Bangkok this guy here the
white guy as you can see him he's been
abusive to these foot massages like you
would be be shocked let me show you some
of it tell me this guy's giving you a
hard time
yeah yeah this man here giving you a
hard time yeah what's he
doing what's he doing
very noisy and very being abusive
yeah why you doing this brother what
country are you
from what country you
from why you come to Thailand and create
a problem with this woman huh
why don't do that again
yeah you're going to do that
again all right don't do that again yeah
don't do that again
that's what I thought and I think I'm
I'm seeing more and more of this uh kind
of phenomena around as um European
tourists coming and um with a very kind
of entitled atud especially to uh people
in the service
industry acting in a very rambunctious
manner so I'm with brother
he's guy he's uh doing Muay Thai here in
Muay Tha in Bangkok he been living in
the gym yeah I live in the gym just had
a fruit what that what's that fruit
called fruit beautiful fruit it's
tun it's unbelievable isn't it it's
unbelievable bro it's tasty bro what do
you think of living in Thailand living
in Thailand bro is like the best
decision but you need to be focused
because it costs money for training for
living and eaing you need to be smart
you need to find a job you can do online
you pure is that what you're doing yeah
yeah that's what I'm doing maybe we'll
see you tomorrow then yeah see you
tomorrow
got
a but you can actually you can um like
you know the equivalent of BL bar you
get an Uber motorbike so this
is all right so kasim you're going to
teach us now the basics of elbows yeah
Mo this is basic for
Mo what's mo mo the distance when you
have the distance this your shoulder
your portex your mouth and when you got
it you try you need to have your fingers
on your chest and open and you protect
you go up to down like a cycle you know
cycle come and be careful you have your
distance you make one step to throw the
elbow oh one step thr the elbow but be
careful you need to step back because it
can give you an elbow back okay distance
elb distance again you see keep my
distance you cannot throw me an elbow
now
[Music]
and SL again and distance again and
after you can walk through the body
after take you don't know where the St
come up down and again elbow okay all
the things together is going to
happen te everything
we're about to eat this food now tell me
what what is this this one is like
chicken yeah with basilic yeah uh with
spicy okay this one is one egg Fri fried
egg with rice this one is like typical
the meal of nightmare of fighter because
you need protein yes after the training
you need it for the vitamine we eat
fruits and now for protain you're going
to eat chicken and eggs Perfect all
right we're in the streets now with the
[Music]
man do you know it's got beautiful
weather Thailand you know tropical
weather fantastic
weather it's very high humidity
though so I'm in the gym and um think
coming here uh quite a lot actually and
been doing the the sessions here they've
got open sessions for everyone that's
what in Thailand I mean I'm in Bangkok
don't forget I mean most people come to
Thailand they come to pet and other
places like that from more time but
Bangkok has got his fair share of uh
gyms as well and um I'm in one
particular gym called Jetty gym who are
known for let's say for example
clinching which is a
particular maneuver or technical style
even more time and um yeah I'm I'm doing
a lot of private here with the
guys and uh you know the pad sessions
can actually be quite a fantastic
workout to be honest with you the pad
sessions and um just you know the bags
you got the bags here show you
around the Ring sparring there the tal
sparring and stuff like that and um yeah
it's pretty good